it's so nice to finally uh be able to
talk to you yeah we've been trying to
set this up after a while
yeah just funny I've been wanting to get
you on here for so long I've been
following you you've been it looks like
you finally put a you've been building a
new house is that what you've been doing
well I wasn't building the house
it was I bought at your house and the
garage basically had just raw
two-by-fours no insulation and there's
no frickin electrical outlets in a whole
garage and so I wired a subpanel
I insulated old garage I added like ten
outlets at about countertop high so I
can plug in hand tools and stuff and
then I dry weld it painted it and now
it's all ready to rock and roll
so that's traction so for the people out
there who may not be familiar with your
story could you give me like a brief
synopsis of your background yeah I mean
a real quick synopsis I grew up on a
farm you know doing horses and cattle
and pigs I was a football player I
played rugby played lacrosse I did a lot
of that stuff and I was pretty good at
it I graduated from high school I went
to Virginia Military Institute and then
after I left College was a Bachelor of
Science in political science Bachelor of
Arts in political science I'm sorry but
then I didn't know what I wanted to do
with my life and right at that time
period Desert Shield and Desert Storm
Kenneth Merrick open so I was nineteen
ninety and immediately when I saw that
were starting I said as an American as a
citizen I'm gonna join the military and
that's what I did I joined with a
specific intent to be a Navy SEAL so
immediately after boot camp I pretty
much went to Navy SEAL training buds and
in our graduated budget atop my class I
had my pick of SEAL team and I picked
SEAL team one I was at SEAL team one for
nine years and then I went on to a
couple of SEAL Teams after that and
after 20 years of seals I've retired and
I was working for the government at
Pentagon and I was retired I had
retirement and so I was kind of let my
hair grow a little
her than a buzz cut that you have
normally from military and then I
started kind of looking back in life and
I found that I defended Liberty and I
defended the pursuit of happiness and I
had neither so I wasn't happy and and I
just was not fulfilling what I would say
would be you know my personal liberty
the individual liberty that we have in
America I think is our greatest asset
the fact that you can live your life you
know as fully as you on and your honor
than anybody else you know do anything
that affects anyone else you know in a
negative way you just want to live your
own personal liberty and so that's what
I said I want to do and at that point I
said hey I'm transgender and I've been
hiding this and afraid my entire life
and starting that day I started living
as Kristin you know I said the heck with
it I'm not gonna put up with with my
living and hiding and and being afraid
all the time and I defended Liberty so
don't I have a chance to live some of
myself and that's what I
I finally came to conclusion and I think
every American should have that same
opportunity to live the full of life
they can without fear
you know without ridicule you know
without being you know prejudiced or
bigotry and and everything else that
comes with the territory of being a
minority or being someone who is you
know disenfranchised from the system and
when I talk about the system I talk
about it's a it's a system that's been
set up around the world for eons and it
has to do with class and the caste
structure and that caste structure is
kind of what has affected us badly in so
many ways because it's so hard to break
you know if you're born into a lower
class you know class if you're born into
a lower caste it's so so difficult to to
get a foot up in order to to raise
beyond you know your birthplace and I
was born into a know a lower middle
class you know blue-collar we worked our
lives my family came from Sweden during
the potato famines and ever
we're going on Europe so we were running
away from famine and pestilence and and
all that and came to America to try to
to try to live a better life and so for
generations my family we've never really
gone past you know very much past that
you know lower middle-class blue-collar
existence we just haven't i opportunity
to raise above that where does not not
that were given the opportunity there
are opportunities out there but it's
very very difficult to get above that
and the only way you can get above that
class or caste system is through
education and opportunity and America
offers great opportunity education it's
difficult you know you need money to get
that education money to go to Harvard
you need to open slot to go to Harvard I
wanted to go to Harvard but I just never
had the opportunity it wasn't it wasn't
available to me because of money or
because of the high schools I went to it
just didn't have the grades I didn't
have the drive I didn't have the
instructors from grade school through
high school if you don't have that you
know seize the day professor and I love
that that movie you know carpe diem and
all that what's that movie called with
Robin Williams wasn't it
seize the day you know go it was a good
Pope's
Dead Poets Society okay okay yeah and
and I love that movie because it just
shows the impact of one professor of one
instructor and if you don't have that
throughout your life you know you're
missing and mentorship you need a mentor
and a lot of people do not ever have a
mentor or an instructor that motivates
I'm beyond just two plus two is four you
know two plus two is eight no it's five
now I'm just even but I just I mean I'm
not saying that I never had the
opportunities I've had great
opportunities but I do think if I would
have had one of those professors maybe
in grade school to just push me a little
bit further to really understand what
it's like to really buckle down and and
do the studies and then go a little bit
beyond and get those grade point
averages and get it up and
where you're at and then you would have
a better opportunity to attend a better
college you know when you're you know at
a college age I just think that those
opportunities aren't offered to a lot of
people you know I wanna get very few
does that mean any sense Oh totally
totally talked a lot about all kinds of
different stops no I think it's I think
it's so fascinating all the things that
you've been able to accomplish in your
life
hey just being able to get through buds
training which is like one of the
hardest things a human could possibly
get through though closest way I can
relate to it is listening to I listen to
David David Goggins book about it which
was actually awesome his brutal details
of trying to survive buzz and failing so
many times like so yeah so when I first
listened to David Goggins book that was
the first time I'd ever even learned
anything about the details of what buds
is like and listening to that was like
being shot up with pure adrenaline just
listening to what he had to deal with
and the fact that you got through that
training on your first attempt is that
right yes can you describe to me with
that process can you paint a picture for
me and for the audience of what that was
like and how grueling that was for you
to get through it and not only that but
what was like the deep down burning
desire for you to get through that
training initially well let me first
cover that I made it through the first
time and I won't I will not say that's a
feed it's a great thing it's like
whatever that because the thing is
getting through buds your first time
second time third time however many
times it takes you it's a matter of luck
it's a matter of timing it's a matter of
where you are in your life because you
figure that you're going through
something that's six months long every
day is a workout every day is a mental
challenge every day is is you being just
exhausted and just made it to the next
day now if you're on the obstacle course
and some of the officer course obstacles
are up 50 60 feet high if you do
anything the slightest mistake when
you're 60 feet off the
and you fall you're not gonna make
through buds if you're on an obstacle
even if it's 10 or 15 feet tall 10 or 15
foot fall could potentially break a leg
and arm it could kill you if you falling
you know fall badly do you know what I'm
saying yeah so every day and buds you're
flipping a coin how lucky am I you're
flipping a coin you know where is my
mental preparation where's all that so
that's the thing is for people who tried
to go through buds and they tried it one
time and they failed for whatever reason
you know I I'm just like dude you just
had a bad day you got unlucky you fell
off that you got hurt here you got that
something happened so but if then a
mental challenge comes into it the
mentality of just perseverance and never
quitting so they made it they missed it
the first time that should have gone the
second time they probably would have
made it a great seal they didn't try
again so there's where they failed so I
would say that you just didn't persist
enough you didn't keep going he didn't
drive hurt if he didn't do that so
there's a lot of equations that you
could say and you could make stuff up
you could say this or that of that of
that and none of its true it's all made
up it's all equations that who's best
prepared to make it through buds I don't
know there's they would have never
thought I would have made it through
because I was like a mediocre athlete
and in high school in college it wasn't
great I was fast I was I would run you
know 15 miles and and do well because I
was just cut it out I had that drive
that just would never ever stop I would
run with a broken leg Goggins talks
about that constantly that he's running
with so huge foot you know blisters on
his feet that he's bleeding through his
sneakers you know what kind of mental
attitude do you have to run a 50 mile
course and your feet are bleeding
that's David Goggins that's almost every
seal I've ever met but it's not
something you have normally or is it
something that everyone has because when
you think about it we are animals we're
part of the animal kingdom just really
high up on a totem pole not the top
because I think sharks are pretty high
when it comes to water
if you're a big burgers it's pretty high
I'm gonna tone it firm for land
creatures and the dinosaurs they're
freakin badass but they're gone
why are the dinosaurs gone those things
were badass they'd crush anything on
earth
t-rex come on man how come we don't have
T Rexes anymore those things were tough
that's the top of the food chain now if
we think we're on the top of the food
chain we're killing ourselves we're
kidding ourselves we're we don't know
what we're talking about so I don't know
man what makes it make somebody gets
through buds the first time second time
third time but I do know that I think we
all have the capability to really dig
into that primitive state that we have
in human beings and it goes into debt a
maga feeling god the crocodile brain
yeah it's fine happy gilmore they make
fun of it croc doula oblongata no but
but the thing is if you can tap into the
crocodile we're in Abdul oblongata if
you can tap into that type of survival
on the real instinct we have as human
beings then you're into something that's
how you make it as a seal you're not
relying on the higher learning that I'm
gonna run for 20 miles and I feet are
gonna bleed out if you're thinking about
your higher learning your higher mental
capacity you're not gonna make it cuz
then you're gonna start overthinking it
you know I'm gonna probably hurt myself
I'm gonna hurt myself badly and I'm I'm
gonna have this injury if you rest of my
life oh man make your alligator brain
talk yeah i alligator brain is telling
me keep going well so that's I don't
there's no equation who knows who makes
it through buds I don't know you're
gonna have the guy who's the freakin
person they call a nerd his entire life
he's amazing our computers and nobody
ever saw him run a mile in his entire
life
and that guy ends up being a top guy
[Laughter]